Drohnen können nicht unendlich groß
werden weil sie nicht unendlich große
Batterien transportieren können
Satelliten im Weltall müssen als Ballast
auch immer noch einen Akku mitschleppen
und bei E-Autos macht der Akku ungefähr
ein Drittel des Gesamtgewichts aus was
passiert aber sobald ein Akku gar nichts
mehr wiegt das haben sich auch
forschende gedacht machen wir doch das
gesamte Auto oder den Laptop oder das
Smartphone selbst zur Batterie wie das
funktioniert und ob bald wirklich alles
um uns herum zu einem Akku werden kann
das zeigen wir euch in diesem Video
[Musik]
bisher galt immer je mehr Power desto
größer und schwerer der Akku das endet
dann in so paradoxen Konstruktionen wie
dass die Batterien zum Beispiel in Autos
immer schwerer werden müssen nur um sich
selbst herumzufahren über zusätzliche
Reichweite kann man erst danach
nachdenken deswegen glauben viele
Forscher dass zum Beispiel Schiffe oder
Flugzeuge nicht im großen Stil
elektrisch werden können das Gewicht der
benötigten Batterie wäre zu groß wenn
aber das Gerät selbst der Akku wäre dann
könnte sich das alles ändern also wie
kann das funktionieren ein Gerät das
einfach selbst eine Batterie ist das
Zauberwort hier heißt strukturbatterie
und davon gibt es ganz grob zwei
verschiedene Varianten da gibt es einmal
die Hülle der Batteriezellen die ohne
Gehäuse einfach direkt ins Gerät
eingebaut wird beim neuen Tesla z.B
bildet die Hülle der Batteriezellen den
Boden des Autos das spart Metall dass
man sonst dafür gebraucht hätte und eine
ähnliche Technik wird schon bei Kerosin
für Flugzeuge angewandt anstatt wie
früher einen Link in den Flügel zu bauen
spart man sich das Gewicht und der Tank
selber ist der Flügel bei der richtigen
strukturbatterie gibt es jedoch nicht
einmal mehr Batteriezellen oder Hüllen
stattdessen wird das ganze Auto oder das
ganze Flugzeug oder was auch immer zum
Akku seine Einzelteile speichern die
Energie hierfür braucht es wie bei einer
normalen Batterie auch ein Material das
den Pluspol bildet eines das den
Minuspol bildet einen Separator
dazwischen und ein Leitermaterial ein
sogenanntes Elektrolyt klingt einfach
ist es aber natürlich Überraschung nicht
denn anstatt diese Teile jetzt einfach
in einen Kasten zu packen wie bei einer
normalen Batterie muss das Material ja
in die Form eines Autos oder eines
Flugzeugs gebracht werden es muss also
bei der Herstellung verformbar sein
zusätzlich muss es dann ja sowohl ein
guter Energiespeicher sein als auch sehr
robust und häufig sind Materialien ja
entweder das eine oder das andere und
als wäre das alles nicht genug verändert
sich das Material auch noch wenn es
geladen ist all das müssen die
Hersteller exakt berechnen können bevor
Sie anfangen groß in die Technologie zu
investieren
okay hört sich ja alles so an als wäre
diese eierlegende Wollmilchsau unmöglich
zu produzieren doch eine Annäherung an
dieses Wundermaterial hat ein
Forschungsteam aus Schweden geschafft
dafür haben Sie folgendes kombiniert
Kohlenstofffasern bilden den negativpol
eine mit Lithium Eisenphosphat
beschichtete Aluminiumfolie den
positiv-pol
Glasfasern separieren das ganze damit es
nicht zum Kurzschluss kommt und das
Elektrolyt besteht ebenfalls aus einem
festen Material damit erhöht es die
Belastungsfähigkeit weiter anschließend
steckten die Forschenden das Ganze unter
Druck in einen Ofen um es weiter
auszuhärten das sorgt unter anderem für
eine besondere dünne der Glasfasern was
wiederum zu der besonders guten
Performance dieser Batterie beigetragen
hat und fertig ist sie die Batterie die
gleichzeitig ein Baustoff ist eine
strukturbatterie die 24 Wattstunden pro
Kilogramm speichert zum Vergleich Diesel
oder Benzin schaffen 11 bis 12000
Kilowattstunden pro Kilogramm normale
Autobatterien rangieren aktuell um 200
Wattstunden also ungefähr das Zehnfache
und einzelne Hersteller sprechen bereits
von einer feststoffbatterie mit bis zu
400 Wattstunden pro Kilogramm man muss
also ganz ehrlich sagen marktreif ist
diese neue Struktur Batterie noch lange
nicht andererseits muss sie ja auch rund
ein Drittel weniger Gewicht
transportieren in Sachen Robustheit
performte diese neue Batterie dann
wiederum sehr gut ihre Steifigkeit also
die Robustheit des Materials lag bei 25
Giga Pascal mit dieser Kombi aus
Speicherkapazität und Steifigkeit
schlägt der neue Akku laut den
Forschenden also alle bisherigen
Struktur Batterien in Zukunft wollen die
Forschenden auch die Aluminiumfolie
durch Kohlefasern ersetzen sie hoffen
dadurch die Energiedichte auf 75
Wattstunden pro Kilogramm zu erhöhen und
die Steifigkeit noch weiter zu steigern
wir haben den Forschungsgruppenleiter
live nach dem Stand der Dinge gefragt
ein weiteres Kohlenstofffaser Aluminium
Folienmaterial mit rund 41 Wattstunden
pro Kilogramm ist gerade fertig geworden
und das Paper hierzu wird nun reviewt an
der Kohlenstofffaser Kohlenstofffaser
Batterie arbeiten sie und eine weitere
schwedische Forschungsgruppe parallel
okay es gibt also erste Schritte noch
einen weiten Weg zu gehen aber auch
jetzt schon Ideen wie die aktuellen
Probleme gelöst werden können super wann
wird denn dann jetzt alles aus Batterie
sein forschende gehen davon aus dass es
noch gut zehn Jahre dauern könnte bis
wir die ersten Autos haben die
gleichzeitig Batterie und nun ja eben
Autos sind auch weil die Entwicklung von
Akkus generell sehr langwierig und teuer
ist jetzt sicher alle schon von Graphen
von luftkeramik oder Glas Batterien
gehört die zwar im Labor toll aber noch
lange nicht marktreif sind aber Autos
sind vielleicht auch die Königsklasse
sie brauchen verhältnismäßig viel
Energie und müssen wahnsinnig viele
Sicherheitsauflagen erfüllen in
kleineren Geräten könnte das Konzept
schon deutlich eher angewendet werden
manche Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftler liebäugeln z.B mit einem
Einsatz in mikrogeräten aus der Medizin
die kleiner als eine Fingerkuppe sind
diese könnten so noch kleiner werden
also wird Batterie all unsere Gewichts-
und Platzprobleme mit Akkus lösen wir
wissen es noch nicht denn vielleicht ist
die Technik gar nicht das non plus ultra
es ist zum Beispiel noch unklar ob und
wie solche Geräte repariert werden
könnten bei den Batterien als Bauteil
wie im Tesla geht das laut einigen
ersten Tüftlern wohl quasi gar nicht und
auch bei den echten Struktur Batterien
gibt es noch einige Unklarheiten wenn
ich zum Beispiel einen Kratzer am Auto
habe und das gleichzeitig ein Kratzer an
der Batterie ist muss man dann direkt
alles austauschen und wie sieht das mit
dem Recycling aus wenn das Gerät aus so
stark miteinander verwobenen Materialien
besteht ihr seht noch ist das Ganze
Zukunftsmusik aber die Forschenden
klingen recht optimistisch dass es
Struktur Batterien zumindest für einige
Geräte in Zukunft geben könnte ziemlich
nervig ist ein Kratzer am Auto übrigens
auch ganz ohne Struktur Batterien hatte
ich nämlich schon mal viel weniger
nervig ist so ein Kratzer aber wenn man
dann gut versichert ist und wer bei
Versicherungen schnell den Überblick
verliert oder grundsätzlich keinen Spaß
an sowas hat für den könnte klar
interessant sein
Tag ist nämlich die Versicherungs App
die für euch den Überblick behält und
regelmäßig überprüft ob ihr die besten
Versicherungen abgeschlossen habt sie
klagt die Möglichkeit euren
Versicherungsschutz zu verbessern dann
schlägt die App euch kostenlos
Versicherungen vor die ihr ganz schnell
und einfach annehmen oder ablehnen könnt
und wenn es bestehende Versicherungen
günstiger oder zum gleichen Preis in
besser gibt dann optimiert Clark euren
Schutz seit neuestem automatisch
vorausgesetzt die widerspricht den
Änderungen nicht innerhalb von 14 Tagen
was ihr natürlich auch machen könnt wer
also gerne die Kontrolle behält der
prüft seine Mails regelmäßig auf
Änderungen für wen sich besser günstiger
oder sogar beides super anhört der lässt
Clark einfach walten wichtig zu wissen
klagt tritt als Makler für euch auf das
ist hilfreich wenn ihr Versicherungen
einfach kündigen oder neue abschließen
wollt das wird aber auch relevant wenn
ihr schon einen Makler habt der gibt
nämlich dadurch sein Mandat anklagt ab
das solltet ihr also unbedingt beachten
wenn ihr diesen Service von Plug
ausprobieren wollt und eure
Versicherungen automatisch optimieren
lassen wollt dann geht gerne auf den
ersten Link unten in der
Videobeschreibung und gibt bei der
Registrierung den Code Watson ein damit
bekommt ihr für bis zu drei bestehende
Versicherungen jeweils einen 15 €
Gutschein für Cyberport Amazon oder den
App Store und natürlich unterstützt ihr
damit auch noch uns und unsere Videos
danke dafür und zurück zu den Batterien
manchmal würde ich ja ganz gerne Wetten
welche dieser ganzen bahnbrechenden
neuen Batterietypen und Energiequellen
zuerst marktreif wird bestimmt die kalte
Kernfusion ihr wisst schon nur noch 30
Jahre und so bis dahin bleibt neugierig